one thing about animation that I find
very interesting is that the character
is more than human the character is
usually exaggerated and so you have to
do something to meet the character
you've got to match this thing sometimes
the character has an enormous head or a
really huge eyes or they're super super
long there's something about them that's
more than human that's Supra human and
so you want to give it your all to match
the look and the image of the character
and that to me is always a lot of fun
because you get to do more stuff you get
to go wild trying to find where that
Medium is for you to be the character
you need the character to be one as
opposed to just playing a human being